Wow getting white again really sorry
after I was just two games not three I
was thinking it's no sorry yeah I've got
three white games in a row that's good
anyway I'm sorry for that but I'm just a
speck which is completely irritating and
I mean two in a row you get quite often
but three that's strange okay yeah Carl
start we have a I am card slot and we
have a night off on the board this line
h3 is so popular and whoa what what kind
of move is that h5 interesting I mean
normal i think the normal response
should be this because they capture
something that top white usually
welcomes in this in this line i get
quick development i can castle long and
before i'm getting back basically I'm
anytime ok so if I cancel him I wonder I
wonder I'm under warm some other I can't
go 93 94 first maybe we should before i
can i can check top so let that pin is
no issue ya hear I'm threatening a 3 in
this position or C 3 it looks a little
bit tricky some develop and look at age
five wow that looks problematic for
black this position
so I can take age 50 fire I mean why not
grab this black forfeits due to
disconnection ok mmm guess you didn't
like his position um I don't know what
did you blunder even more which I didn't
spot no I don't think so I will check ok
that's a very brief game but I think
it's so interesting to em to post
because of the opening variation which
might be useful for some people yeah h3
is my line against the night off its is
interesting why does preparing g4 I mean
very in a very clear way just this is
it's not the only idea of the move but
it's the like ninety-five percent of it
is to blade you form yeah a six or a
5-under main replies and after it six of
course g4 is played yeah I'd here and
black has some choices we can play an we
should be 796 source development moves
age six is an interesting move to
prevent any g5s um also there's this b5
now enters g5 for a long while d5 was
one of the principled reactions to this
and white and usually replied like this
yeah after which Bishop t4 is best and
to be honest I also think that this is a
little bit better for white I don't
think a black ever got the complete
equality in this but as it turns out the
move that are played 90 32 now it's
becoming a popular and yeah this it is
interesting why does keeping this this
tension in the center here it does not
capture and it seems that black probably
should go we should be formed something
like and all those captures they usually
lead to problems yeah something like
this is very comparable to the game the
game was just even more
with age 5 and g5 inserted but this is
already good for white I get long
castles this is going to be a yeah we
captured soon and why just has far more
active pieces in issue is also that a
success plate yeah that weakens b6 quite
a bit so that's not very comfortable we
should be form is one of the better
movie I think and then a three is played
yeah this sir this is probably leading
into sin to straight difficulties
because he has to take now only for
otherwise you just submit let's just do
this the porn for no no nothing at all
so my god dressing and now be should be
three Karen this is not comfortable the
only is very much of an annoyance you
cannot um yeah move anything on the
kingside all that easily so 96 going
here we have issued before okay i can
cancel with check and now the engine
wants you to go to c7 i pant like this
this is the issue this pawn is absolute
annoyance for black now if you move
something like this night will come to
d5 with great effect ok went to e7 and
now I'm am yam threatening a 30 c 3 with
Bishop c5 coming wow we should be to
gant well that's the problem i am
threatening this a 3c three moves h5 is
hanging so what he did is there's
nothing much better let's say I'm
Black is just in bad shape okay not
enough to resign maybe but yeah I
understand that he wasn't happy with the
situation so not a let's say a complete
game in a way but maybe it's still
useful for people to to get an idea what
this age 3 is all about against the
night off ok guys thanks for watching